[Music]
that looks so real i got scared
they pulled all her pots for taking
cheap shots
chrissy teigen the super stupid
supermodel famous for marrying john
legend
she's also known for being a complete
jerkface on twitter but now the one who
love to cancel anyone for laughs is
experiencing her own turn in the barrel
after decade-old tweets resurfaced of
her bullying reality star courtney
stodden
who was 16 at the time teagan had
encouraged her to kill herself
stodden was the only person tegan
targeted she was a true anomaly a
well-known celebrity who delighted in
marshalling her millions of followers to
swarm anyone
she thought was her inferior she loved
to bully and it showed
but now her reign of mean girl terror is
over
major retailers like bloomingdale's are
pulling chrissy's cookware line
from their shelves luckily she won't
need them since her goose is
already cooked meanwhile
joe rogan says woke canceled culture
will only escalate until straight white
men
are silenced you can never be woke
enough that's the problem it keeps going
it keeps going further and further and
further down the line and if you get
to the point where you capitulate where
you
agree to all these demands it will
eventually get to
straight white men are not allowed to
talk oh those will be the days
now a lot of dumb people like cnn's don
lemon were quick to point out that rogan
has an audience of millions and no one's
trying to silence him
no crap he wasn't talking about himself
a concept don lemon doesn't seem to
understand
speaking of here's don giving his take
on canceled culture
if you believe that america is for
everyone then you certainly believe that
america is about redemption america is
about redemption and is not
just about canceling people
uh okay dawn dawn now meet
don then i have many people who i love
in my life and yeah i come from a red
state i've lived in several red states
there are a lot of friends who i had to
really get rid of because they
they are so nonsensical when it comes to
this issue they have the whole
every single talking point that they
hear on state tv and that they hear from
this president
they repeat it and they are blinded by
it i had to get rid of them
because they are too far gone oh my god
that's beautiful
by the way don didn't you say you were
leaving a few days ago
that's the only cnn exclusive america
wishes were true
hi kid i forgive you dawn i forgive you
for every awful stupid thing you
said about fox too i'll forgive you for
that too
all right joey uh your pick chrissy or
joe
oh i like them both what are you talking
about all right then do a 288.1.2
no here's the deal with chrissy teigen
she announced she was leaving twitter on
march 24th
and she was back on i believe april 16th
and
so that i think she made 20 days
without tweeting all right you're
welcome
lent is 40 days americans every single
year
go twice as long without sex or alcohol
they give up bread for 40 days and she
couldn't go 20 days without tweeting
and when she finally came back she's
just stepping off in it and this is why
she has social media personality
disorder right she's addicted to this
attention
and if you live in that world long
enough your own
ire will be directed right back at you
because we are human beings and we do
stupid things
on the point of joe rogan and don lemon
the problem
that don lemon has with joe rogan is
that joe rogan has something don will
never have
don lives in a world where you claim
superiority by having this wisdom
and intelligence and everyone knows it's
not true in this world that we live in
this right this tv right
when we go on tv we have to be saying
like hey mom and dad this is how you can
understand
all the bull crap they're telling you
that's all our job is but cnn it's not
like that
that's why five people watch it joe
rogan is a celebrity because he
manipulated people into sticking their
hands into boxes of scorpions
or eating insects and then he maneuvered
that into making fun of his friends
while they beat up each other
and now he gets high and talks about
random things he's just an
interesting human being and that kills
him yeah that kills don
massively successful uh mercedes tegan
or joe or do you want to mush it into a
tegan
joe sandwich that could be uh that could
be pretty gross
um but you might have to use tegan's uh
cookware for that but
let me tell you i think she has martha
stewart syndrome
really she wants to be martha stork but
she goes topless when she's cooking i
mean
that's kind of the thing i don't think
we want to see martha topless
i mean think about you completely don't
cook topless especially bacon
as i've learned just be careful with the
oil
but it's really hot yes you know i think
when you look at joe
uh dawn's just jealous i mean he's so
jealous of joe
we can't stand this moral moralizing
speeches that don lemon gives every
night it's really good to put it on if
you want to put the kids to sleep just
put dawn on
but really joe rogan has been a
sensation he's been a social media
sensation he's been able to attract
over 11 million people per episode
and you know what this country's about
freedom of speech we're going to stand
for it
we're going to make sure that every
american can speak freely
and not be silenced by the left you know
i would love to silence kat
[Applause]
well said uh cat but do you buy the
white do you
would you say this is white man whining
or
no look i think i don't know joe rogan
may have gone a bit far saying that
white guys are not going to be allowed
outside
soon especially just i don't they won't
do it they won't do it like the
there's a lot of frat guys that have
been locked inside way too long they are
not going to miss another summer of day
drinking bud lights on rooftops there's
no way
i've seen them out and they are excited
to be back
yes but i thought something he said
elsewhere that was really
really really important was there's
people we should be nice to each other
but there's people whose entire identity
is
looking for things that other people
have done wrong and trying to cancel
them right
i don't think chrissy teigen is only
mean because she told someone
who was 16 to kill themselves yeah
that's really mean
it's pretty mean to make your entire
purpose for being alive
trying to destroy someone else's life in
livelihood
that's not nice and just because you're
doing it in the name of wokeness it
doesn't make you nice you're still
a jerk yeah you know emily i realize
that chrissy teigen was your hero
[Laughter]
and we've noticed cut out in your office
i've been watching a lot of uh
outnumbered and i see what you've
you've been kind of adopting some of her
traits do you see it are you trying to
take the spot that she's vacated you
false i objects not true uh i just feel
like
for this this is no surprise to us who
saw through
how shallow and how performative all of
that activism is from the left anyway of
course she would turn out to be the
ugliest monster there was
because her facade was that she was the
most beloved perfect human
for her to to tirade and for her to
bully that 16 year old
that is beyond disgusting and yet she's
obviously been throwing those arrows the
whole time
and then on the joe rogan don lemon don
lemon pointed out the massive platform
that joe rogan has and that's absolutely
right as we've been saying here compared
especially with don lemon's
pitiful viewership he also ignored the
context of the podcast which
in that is that joe rogan was talking
about the arena of comedy
specifically but you know he said it
best which is that you can never be too
woke and that's the problem another
reason quick that chrissy teigen's the
worst
is because she's like super super rich
but she makes her whole pretending to be
relatable like
i ate too much bread huh well then have
some come to your house and give you a
colon cleanse on demand because you can
afford that
you're not the same what a brawn that is
the worst thing about it is that she is
she's why is somebody who's supposed to
be so successful
punching down i do that that's mine
but also the too much information stuff
oh yeah that's a whole nother side where
she's talking about their sex life
personality disorder that's what it is
it's the addiction to attention
yeah i like that they're playing the
music they can play through the whole
show i went on brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now